people used to use paper calendars now
over 500 million people en counting use
digital calendars on their phones and
computers to organize their lives but
aside from saving trees the only major
evolution is the ability to send
reminders and schedule meetings with
people using the same calendar which
means trying to schedule a meeting with
people outside of your organization is
like a nightmare of email and phone call
pingpong different time zones are caused
for Mass confusion and it doesn't really
help you to be more productive or
efficient it just records your events
but here's the thing your calendar knows
a lot about you your schedule who you
meet with where you go when you go hey
with all that knowledge shouldn't your
calendar be doing more for you the folks
at tungle think so which is why they're
transforming the calendar into an
intelligent service that takes all the
information you give it and gives back
insights that help you manage your life
not just your time they started by
solving the scheduling problem you can
share your availability and schedule
meetings easily across different
organizations and time zones and the
people you're scheduling with don't even
have to sign up to use it but that's
just the beginning tungle preps you for
meetings by giving you background info
on the companies and people you're
meeting with from sources like LinkedIn
and Facebook and Google in the future
tungo will even help you schedule your
personal and professional life based on
things like your priorities location
preferences and important commitments so
imagine a calendar that doesn't just
keep track of birthdays but even suggest
where to shop according to who you're
buying for and what's on the way to your
next meeting or imagine a calendar that
recommends the best route from one
meeting to another using traffic
patterns weather in time of day imagine
a calendar that gives back as much as
you put in tongle did and they're making
it happen so what are you waiting for
sign up now at tungle domme